[Musica]
[Applauso]
a spa né a spanne dal dialetto
piemontese non si fa se credessimo a
tutto ciò che ci viene detto alle
negazioni imposte alla poca fiducia
talvolta riposta nell'innovazione
non andremo certamente lontano
fortunatamente c'è chi crede nel futuro
e prima ancora di tutto in se stesso
iniziano così viaggi e rocamboleschi
alla ricerca di una soluzione ad una
domanda che ancora non esisteva tra
immaginazione e realtà in quel limbo
sottile ma così intrigante da tagliare
la mente a progetti innovativi in un
futuro surreale
vi siete mai trovati nella complicata
condizione di dover realizzare la vostra
ambizione
vi siete mai trovati in quel limbo
destabilizzante di non comprendere più
se siano più forti le vostre origini
vostre radici il vostro futuro
la vostra ambizione è di sentirvi dire
non si può fare non si fa
ecco io sì e questo mi ha sempre dato la
forza per combattere e vincere su quei
no quelli inutili ricordo che quando ero
bambino ero un bambino timido e
silenzioso
al tempo stesso ero carico di energia
voglia di disegnare di creare e di
sognare alle
sette anni al tempo stesso mio cugino
gigi vinceva il mondiale rally e per me
lui era un faro una luce di successo
decido così di comprare un album dai
disegni e una matita e iniziò a
replicare sulla carta le auto che
vincevano le gare quella matita tutt'a
un tratto era diventata la chiave della
mia stanza segreta dove potevo
rifugiarmi qualsiasi volta lo volessi è
la stanza della creatività la creatività
che è l'unico lusso che tutti noi ci
possiamo concedere in qualsiasi ambito
e così anche a scuola i quaderni di
matematica diventavano delle officine
perché in case lavo nei quadretti le
automobili e quelli di italiano
diventavano delle piste sulle quali far
correre sulle cui righe far correre le
mie le ruote della mia fantasia fuori da
quel banco fuori da quell'aula fuori da
quel la scuola fuori da quella città
fuori e qualche volta una voce mi
chiamava alla lavagna e quella era la
maestra lei probabilmente non aveva le
chiavi della mia stanza e non sapeva
dove fossi io
e così erano anche gli anni delle
delusioni perché miei quaderni tornavano
a casa vestiti di rosso
decido di buttare via quella chiave e
iniziò a impegnarmi a scuola passano le
elementari passo le medie ma il secondo
anno del liceo classico
all'inizio di una statua vedo il mio
nome appeso come il primo dei perdenti
un unico bocciato è quel loro io il
percorso che fece successivamente non
annientò mai quella ghigliottina della
vergogna sulla coscienza
anzi li aumenta la rabbia e la fame di
riscatto cresceva vertiginosamente
alimentandosi dentro di me come un
mostro
nell'anno delle decisioni
andai a ricercare quella chiave e riaprì
quella stanza dove c'era forse la mia
unica forza e così a 19 anni prende un
treno e vado a torino a imparare a
disegnare le automobili quella che era
passione diventa così studio per poi
diventare lavoro per poi diventare
realtà imprenditoriale che due anni fa
mi ha permesso di creare il primo
marchio di automobili italiane eco
sostenibili ad alte prestazioni
ma tornando alle origini quella stanza
era a parte le auto e camion era una
fucina di intuizioni e di idee perché
dagli sono uscite le sorpresine kinder i
giocattoli le architetture gli occhiali
ma la strada per emergere era ardua
perché ai colloqui vengono rubati
disegni e nei centri stile viene messa
la firma di noi creativi ma nel 2013
esce anche una notizia in prima pagina
sul corriere della sera che dice un
giovane italiano disegnato l'automobile
più venduta in cina è un'automobile che
sorride che porta positività perché
assomiglia al pesciolino nemo della walt
disney
ed in effetti in effetti aveva
effettivamente aveva replicato gli
stessi tratti somatici su quella
macchina del pesciolino tutta la stampa
italiana mi insegue così anche la mia
azienda che ha una reazione furibonda
durante il processo durato un anno e
mezzo davanti ai giudici era difficile
dimostrare che quell'auto l'avevo
disegnate affitti effettivamente io ma
fece capire che per lo stesso linguaggio
stilistico era stato utilizzato in tutti
gli altri prodotti che avevo disegnato
nel corso del tempo
e così vinco la battaglia della verità
da quel momento decide che devo
disegnare auto che portano soltanto il
mio nome e che sono legate
indissolubilmente a quella natura dove
ero cresciuto fra le mie montagne le mie
dolomiti dove l'aria è pulita e dove
l'acqua
sgorga dalle sorgenti la mia auto doveva
essere testimonial e vanto della
mobilità eco sostenibile la mobilità
pulita sono in cina in e nun nel mezzo
della silk road la via della seta e a
gesù una megalopoli di 9 milioni e se di
abitanti una notte dall'alto di un hotel
riscopro con sorpresa che un mio disegno
fatto quindici anni prima non era
invecchiato era rimasto giovane come un
quadro di dorian gray è così deciso di
realizzarlo e di metterlo su strada
torna in italia insieme alla complicità
la passione l'entusiasmo del mio amico
paolo e poi socio decidiamo di mettere
assieme una squadra di eccellenze
manifatturiere italiane per creare un
automobile che fosse un connubio fra
alta tecnologia in massima artigianalità
italiana
eravamo in aprile e ideare di presentare
l'auto in giugno 2016 al salone di
torino il nome frangivento perché
qualsiasi cosa che si muove frangivento
spesso all'uscita di queste aziende ci
si trovava sulla porta con una deludente
pacca sulla spalla e un us fund e questo
aspan en.mi risuonava nella testa mentre
dormivo non c'erano decido di andare da
salvatore il papà di paolo in officina e
di chiaro ma che cosa vuol dire asfa nen
salvatore lui mi dice giorgio guarda che
la spagna vuol dire non si fa non si può
fare in dialetto piemontese non ce la
faremo mai ad arrivare al salone di
torino
la grinta e la determinazione
aumentavano un minuto dopo minuto così
come le notti insonni e 6 giugno 2016
al salone di torino esordiva davanti ai
riflettori della stampa mondiale davanti
ad una folla di curiosi
quell'auto che portava il nome di as far
as fan e la contrazione di quel detto
demoralizzante era diventato il nostro
cavallo di battaglia per sconfiggere
tutte quelle opposizioni che trovavamo
fra noi e il nostro sogno e di sogni ne
abbiamo tutti e qui in platea
ognuno di voi sicuramente ne ha uno in
testa innamoratevi dal vostro sogno e
conquistate lo perché si può fare
as pane
[Applauso]
[Musica]